Melanson trap mode beatbox this shiz
Nass
it's Friday we're gonna make some curry
I'm gonna get it dinner on the ground
the chicken put the sweet potatoes in
cut the cauliflower and make it ring
it's gonna be a great curry
we're gonna have a curry party what what
huh Oh what hairy party what goodbye doc
Alicia hey guys I'm Abby sharp welcome
to Abby's kitchen if you've been on the
Abby's kitchen blog you've maybe noticed
my recipe for paleo chicken curry this
is the number-one recipe on the abbeys
kitchen blog simply because you know
it's so flavorful it's so easy and it's
packed with nutrition this one pot
wonder has a lot going on so you got
your protein you've got your carbs
you've got loads of veggies going in it
is an amazingly simple really colorful
recipe that your whole family is gonna
love let's do this
I add a tablespoon of olive oil to a pan
then add in some chicken thighs skin
side down and cook them for about 3
minutes per side on medium-high heat
season them with a little bit of salt
and pepper
[Music]
and then once they're nice and
golden-brown you can transfer them to a
plate then back to the pan and I add
some chopped onions garlic ginger curry
powder coriander cumin cayenne and some
salt give everything a good stir and
then add in some tomato sauce some day
sweet potato and give everything a good
stir to get it nice and coated then I
Nestle in my cooked chicken top it off
with my chopped cauliflower some stems
from my rainbow chard and some coconut
milk
a little bit of salt and pepper
and pop the lid on to let everything
cook through once the chicken is fully
cooked we're gonna add in some frozen
edamame and of course all the leaves
from our beautiful rainbow chard a
little bit more salt and pepper to taste
give it a good stir and then pop the lid
on just for a few more minutes to let
everything wilt down I like to serve
mine on a big beautiful bed of quinoa
it's a really nutritious way to carry
all of those flavors throughout the dish
and of course soak up all that yummy
curry sauce top it off with some golden
raisins some pistachios and some
cilantro
[Music]
so guys I hope you enjoy the number one
recipe on the abbeys kitchen blog if you
do be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below some of your
family's favorite go-to weeknight meals
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]